russia
with the largest territory in the world
has roughly the same total population as
nigeria
a country 1 16 its size but this
similarity won't last long
one of the populations is rapidly
growing while the other
is slowly declining what can this tell
us about the two countries
population statistics are some of the
most important data social
scientists and policy experts have to
work with
but understanding a country's situation
and making accurate predictions
requires knowing not just the total size
of the population
but its internal characteristics such as
age and gender
distribution so how can we keep track of
all that data
in a way that makes it easy to
comprehend complex data is more easily
interpreted through visualization
and one of the ways that demographers
represent the internal distribution of a
population is the population pyramid
here the data is divided by gender with
females on one side
and males on the other the population
numbers are shown for each 5 year age
interval
starting from 0 to 4 and continuing up
to 100 and up
these intervals are grouped together
into pre-reproductive
0-14 reproductive 15-44
and post-reproductive years 45 and up
such a population pyramid can be a
powerful predictor of future population
trends
for example rwanda's population pyramid
shows it to be a fast growing country
with most of the population being in the
youngest age groups at the bottom of the
pyramid
the number will grow rapidly in the
coming years as today's children reach
their reproductive years
and have children of their own the total
population is almost certain to double
within the next few decades
for our second example let's look at
canada where most of the population is
clustered around the middle of the graph
because there are less people in the
pre-reproductive age groups
than there are in the reproductive ones
the population will grow
more slowly as the number of people
reaching their reproductive years
decreases
finally let's look at japan because the
majority of its population is in its
post-reproductive years
and the number of people is smaller at
each younger interval
this means that at current rates of
reproduction the population will begin
to decline
as fewer and fewer people reach
reproductive age
comparing these three population
pyramids side by side shows us
three different stages in the
demographic transition as a country
moves from a pre-industrial society
to one with an industrial or
post-industrial economy
countries that have only recently begun
the process of industrialization
typically see an increase in life
expectancy and a fall in child mortality
rates
as a result of improvements in medicine
sanitation
and food supply while birth rates remain
constant
leading to a population boom developing
countries that are farther along in the
industrialization process
begin to see a fall in birth rates due
to factors such as
increased education and opportunities
for women outside of child
rearing and a move from rural to urban
living
that makes having large families less
economically advantageous
finally countries in advanced stages of
industrialization
reach a point where both birth and death
rates are low
and the population remains stable or
even begins to decline
now let's take a look at the projected
population pyramids for the same three
countries
in 2050. what do these tell us about the
expected changes
in each country's population and what
kinds of factors can alter the shape of
these future pyramids
a population pyramid can be useful not
only as a predictor of a country's
future
but as a record of its past russia's
population pyramid
still bears the scars of world war ii
which explains both the fewer numbers of
elderly men compared to elderly women
and the relatively sudden population
increase as soldiers returned from the
war
and normal life resumed china's
population pyramid reflects the
establishment of the one child policy
35 years before which prevented a
population boom such as that of rwanda
but also led to sex selective abortions
resulting in more male children
than female children finally the pyramid
for the united states
shows the baby boom that followed world
war ii
as you can see population pyramids tell
us far more about a country than just a
set of numbers
by showing both where it's been and
where it's headed within a single image
and in today's increasingly
interconnected world facing issues such
as food shortages
ecological threats and economic
disparities it is increasingly important
for both scientists and policy makers
to have a rich and complex understanding
of populations
and the factors affecting
you